yeah I mean you can fake it too make it
in a lot of areas particularly if you're
working for somebody else but at the end
of the day if you're going to be great
at something you've got to make the
effort to be great at something whether
it's Sports whether it's physics math
science business whatever it may be you
know it's not just a natural skill
you've got to to learn and particularly
if you're in the technology industry
because it changes every day you know
when I got started I was a bartender
when I first came to Dallas got into the
PC industry got fired started my own
company but I learned early on that
there was always something new and most
people didn't put in the time to learn
it it's like now with artificial
intelligence lots of people talk about
artificial intelligence lots of people
talk about machine learning and neural
networks not a lot of people are putting
in the time to take classes or do the
tutorials or to learn how to apply it to
business and that's what it takes and
you know that's just something I've
always enjoyed so I've been fortunate
need motivation watch the top 10 rules
video with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I struggled
to believe in myself I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was watching the successful
stories of entrepreneurs they gave me
the inspiration to keep going as well as
the strategies of what to do and quite
honestly I still need their stories and
motivation today as well so today let's
learn from one of the best Mark Cuban
and my take on his top 10 rules of
success
enjoy
rule number two is be a good leader you
may not be a leader to anybody more than
you know the two people who work for you
but it's still a responsibility and I
think
um as you gain more success however you
define that
um being a leader becomes more and more
important how you define success becomes
more and more important what you're able
to do and the impact you're able to have
becomes more and more important where I
am in my life at this point
um it means trying to accomplish things
that I've dreamed about but was never in
a position to try to accomplish or
succeed at and and that's what I'm
trying to do now rule number three is
know your business I think people will
always stop and say well I want to start
a business what should I do and if you
don't know you're not ready right you
know you've got to have something that
you're good at and if you're going to be
if you're going to do it you got to be
the best at it because I'll tell them
look if I come in and compete with you
I'm going to kick your ass are you ready
to compete with me right and you've got
to work like there's someone working 24
hours a day to take it away from you
rule number four is commit yourself to
learning I'm not a big Mentor guy I've
always been a believer that if you
really want to learn something and be
great at something you have to put in
the time a lot of people look for
mentors as shortcuts when in reality
maybe they help you a little bit maybe
they help you avoid some mistakes but
when you're just getting started out in
particular it's okay to make those
mistakes and more importantly you have
to make the commitment to put in the
time to learn what you need to learn to
be great at something or good at what
you want to be good at also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free work worksheet just for
this video the worksheet will highlight
all the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is always look
for new ideas what are you looking for
when you get pitched like top to I mean
you get pitched on television your real
life you clearly like just in the
restaurants and the restaurants yeah
um I look for something that makes me
think why didn't I think of that you
know or it makes me think oh my goodness
that's a good idea and then the
follow-up questions are you know is it
differentiated enough can they protect
it what's the unique element and then
the secondary parts of that or not even
secondary the the other part of it is
you know how good an entrepreneur is and
can I help them and so once you get once
I get past those initial hurdles whether
it's Shark Tank or just you know people
emailing me literally I've invested well
over 100 million dollars in the company
is for people I've never met to this day
interesting rule number six is become a
nicer person my biggest regret was I
wasn't as nice as I should have been you
know um
in my mind I didn't suffer any fools
right if if you if I didn't think you
were using common sense then I would get
annoyed and no one liked to be around me
when I was annoyed and for me it was
just like faster faster faster faster
the Train's speeding up how fast can we
go
um that was a huge regret that I would
do over again
um
I think with the Mavericks when we had
our problem
um
with sexual harassment and I wasn't
there to oversee it I thought by that
point in time I wasn't you know I like
today I didn't go into the office ever
and so I missed it and it hurt a lot of
people and and and that was awful
um
so I'd say you know those two things are
probably the low lights in my career
rule number seven is spend on
experiences the best money I ever spent
was when I bought a lifetime pass on
American Airlines right after I sold my
first company I got really really
inebriated with a bunch of my really
good friends and they were all like what
are you gonna do what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do and you know I'm
not a fancy guy as you can tell you know
I'm not into this and that but I like to
travel I like to have fun and I bought a
lifetime pass on American Airlines for
125 000 which let me travel a hundred
thousand miles I think a year for the
rest of my life so if today if all of a
sudden I turned 20 years old with 20 in
my pocket and this crazy year 2020 could
I be successful again the answer is yes
and I'll tell you exactly what I would
do I'd get any job any job at all that
allows me to pay my bills doesn't matter
what it is because now now I know I can
learn from anything that I do number two
now that I have a little bit of a tech
background or a lot Tech background I
teach myself to do Amazon Alexa and
Google home skills a lot of people have
Amazon Alexa in particular and they know
how to use it generically but they don't
know how customizable it is so I would
just like I did back in the days when I
started micro Solutions and I went to
all these different retail stores
handing out my business cards saying if
you ever have questions or need help
with PCS and computers I'm your guy I
would do the same thing now rule number
eight is be an encourager I look for
leadership I look for a few things one
it's somebody who can relate to people
someone who can define a vision someone
who is nice and someone who recognizes
that it truly comes down to helping
people achieve their personal goals and
aligning those with the goals of the
organization if you can take the goals
of your organization whether it's your
company or somebody you work for and
align them with the interests of the
people that work for you you'll be a
great leader and you also have to
recognize in this day and age people
aren't looking for Lifetime jobs at a
company they want jobs that will help
them improve their own skill sets so
they can find a better place in life
that they enjoy and if you help people
realize their personal goals like that
great things will happen for you as a
leader rule number nine is help others I
think now I I've really evolved some of
my focus to trying to help disadvantaged
entrepreneurs people who have less
opportunity I just invested with the
woman Arlen Hamilton
who we've together created a little
million dollar fund where she's going
out and finding 10 businesses run by
people of color or disadvantaged lgbtq
type communities and just opening doors
because I think my my experience applies
to anybody right any entrepreneur no
matter what you're trying to sell and I
also think that it's a great business
opportunity simply because
the the
markets that they want to sell to are
underserved there just aren't as many
entrepreneurs so there's more
opportunity and so I I think it makes
great business sense as well animal
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is look for experts
whether business or Sports when building
your team are you more interested in
getting someone who is an expert or
something or would you rather have
someone with more potential question of
the day
Olivier
I want an expert
everybody's got potential
everybody I want someone who knows
something give me someone who knows
there's every time because then I can
turn it into something real the key to
being successful and achieving your
dreams no matter what they are is
finding something you really really like
to do and being great at it when you're
great at something you get to write your
own ticket so I'm always going to hire
the expert if you just have potential
chances are you're working for the
expert
generally speaking uh Mark as we've kind
of wind things up here you have lived
your life as an iconoclast and in a way
that's a template for other people but
in a way it isn't so in other words how
much you've got an ordinary person
ordinary man or woman how much of an
Acana class could you or should you be
like Mark Cuban oh I don't care just you
should just be yourself right I mean I
take pride in the fact that I didn't
give us what anybody thought or said I
was just going to be myself and you know
on my dad's son on my mom's son I'm my
brother's brother you know um Alexis
Alyssa and Jake's father Tiffany's
husband
this you know I just try to do the best
like everybody else I mean I've been
blessed you know like I say all the time
I'm the luckiest guy in the world and I
just try not to take it for granted I
try to enjoy every minute and I think
now as I've gotten a little bit older I
try to give a little bit more back than
I have before and and try to help more
people and I you know in terms of
whatever if anybody else finds himself
in my position just enjoy the moment
enjoy every minute of it I mean I guess
my question is are you a role model for
people in society
I don't know I mean I never thought of
it I mean it's not something I try to be
I just try to be myself you know I just
try to to help where I can do what I can
be a good dad and you know I I don't I'm
not trying to be something for somebody
else just myself in terms of content
there's never too much content there's
just because what we want and who we are
and how we consume content
changes every day through our
experiences the challenge of content
isn't can you make it or is there too
much the challenge of content whether
it's business content the proposals you
make what you put on your website how
you connect to people is can you tell a
good story
you know and now storytelling has
evolved it used to be we all congregated
around the TV and there were 250
channels but you know it was the best
alternative to boredom you come home
you're worn up you sit there one hand
goes in the pants the other hand goes on
the beer and you watch TV now all the
content comes to us no matter where we
are there's there's a source of content
and who we are and how old we are and
our experiences that defines what we
like just go to Twitch like I have a
nine-year-old son who plays fortnite all
day every day if we would let him right
and he'll watch Ninja
now ninja is a I don't know if you all
know who he is he's like big guy on
Twitch that streams fortnite games and
um he came to the Mavs practice facility
one day because we got to be friends
just through random sources he was a
bigger star than when Tom Hanks came to
visit I mean and this is a guy on Twitch
now
twitch is unlimited options of content
related to gaming and other things and
they're expanding YouTube obviously just
unlimited content and it's not like
YouTube's struggling where the the
takeaway from all this is when there's
so many options for Content as business
people you have to figure out how to
connect with people you have to know
your audience and you have to know how
to tell a story and honestly that's not
my strength I literally and I forget the
name of the book I'd have to look at my
phone I'm reading a book on storytelling
because that's how people connect we
have so many choices if you can't absorb
us with something that engages us a
story and simplified into a story that
we want to connect with
the next person is going to be who come
the next person is going to come in and
take your business I get that question
all the time so what industry should I
look at I can tell I can tell you all
about artificial intelligence computer
vision personalized medicine
but then what right and so the and maybe
you're an expert in one of those fields
and you can go for it but what I tend to
try to tell people in terms of what does
it take to be successful find something
you love to do and then be great at it
not average
not marginal not good enough but if you
can be great at it be great at it if you
are the the greatest videographer in the
history of videographers
people don't care about cell phones
what is it that you can do that makes
them know that what you the way you do
it is special
and if you can do that and convey it
then you'll be fine if you're not sure
then you know you've got it you've got
to decide whether you want to stay on
your own get it you know be a contractor
or go work for somebody you know it just
depends you know and let me add one
other thing
I I crushed myself
um and like my brothers didn't they they
took a completely different path and
they were looking just nine to five at
yada yada not everybody's got to be an
entrepreneur and so if you if you've got
it in your blood and that's what you
want to do then find a way to be great
and if not you know you'll figure it out
you'll find something else now I'm going
through and teaching myself neural
networks and you know doing the same
thing with machine learning and Gans and
this and that because AI is going to
have more of an impact than the internet
did AI plus new types of chipsets plus
5G is going to change things far more
than we've ever seen anything change and
understanding where and how to apply it
is going to be critical but just as
important knowing how to segregate and
separate the yeah right is as
important because every email you all
are about to send me is going to say I
have this AI solution and we're using
algorithms
yeah of course you are right and then
what what really makes you different
what really sets you apart but if I
didn't do that work if I didn't sit down
and do the AWS machine learning
tutorials if I didn't go on YouTube and
take you know the NYU introduction to
neural networks or whatever I'm not
going to know it I'm not going to be
able to apply it and I'm not going to be
able to be first and that's fun that's
fun knowing I get to kick the ass to
some 22 year old NYU graduate that's
awesome I'd like to talk a little bit
about failure uh you know you've had
some uh and famously I think you've been
were fired from your from early jobs
right which forced you to be an
entrepreneur where there were there any
uh failures that you know in hindsight
were just super valuable and like set
you on the path yeah yeah I mean I
learned more from the places I got fired
from and the places I worked that I
hated than I did from the places I liked
you know I learned what not to do you
know I got fired because I went to close
a sale
um instead of opening up a retail store
and sweeping the floor yada yada
um thinking that when I brought back a
check from a closed deal he would be all
excited and he fired me
um I learned from that that sales cures
all you know that that company was out
of business not much later yeah and you
know it just taught me so many lessons
about how to deal with things how to
treat people what to focus on and that
led to you know me getting started and
also taught me that you know when I was
living six guys in a three bedroom
apartment I had nothing to lose nothing
right and so being young was a perfect
time to start a business because what
was my downside you know we taking the
seventh roommate yeah
and so you you know there's so much I
learned from the places where things on
the surface seem to go wrong but I
learned what not to do and sometimes
that's just as important as what you do
do you think like let's just say if we
put 10 guys here you'll interview them
okay you could within a 5-10 minute
interview say this dude's not gonna make
it as an entrepreneur could you pretty
much know that you know I'm not very
good at interviewing the issue is my
interview skills more than really yo I'm
horrible yeah Shark Tank interview well
yeah it is but I get to do due diligence
after the fact right so I get to play my
engines but I get to check yeah I mean I
can I can typically tell right I can
tell
um but by um
their passion I can tell by their focus
I can tell by their preparation you know
there's a whole realm of things in any
business here you know here's here's the
business you're in and here's a thousand
things that influence whether or not
you're going to be successful and really
to me by you know through my experience
and businesses I can put myself in his
position and say okay here are 900 of
the thousand things he has to be aware
of and then go through and ask and by
how many of those or her
um issues they've been able to address
already that kind of gives me a sense of
how hard they're willing to work you
know and I can tell by the questions
they ask me so all I have to do is say
okay what do you want to know and you
know when they start saying what should
I do they ask you yeah yeah and that's
fine right and I want them to ask
questions but you know people like to
say you know the only stupid questions
are the one you don't ones you don't ask
and that's not right right because the
questions you ask tell everybody tell me
tell whoever more about you than
anything else you do because in
particular tells me about your
preparation if you ask me questions
questions about just basic things that
you should have known and you should
have down to a science
that's going to disqualify you almost
more than anything when I got to Dallas
I was a bartender at night and I moved
in one of my buddies from Indiana said
you got to come to Dallas and I'm like
I'm there you know my car would only get
so far I had a Fiat x19 with a hole in
the floorboard that guzzled oil every 60
miles and I went down there in this
place called The Village it's the world
was the world's largest apartment
complex we had six guys in a
three-bedroom apartment I didn't have my
own room I didn't have my own drawer I
didn't have my closet I had a pile and I
had one ratty towel that I stole from
Motel 6.
um and that was it and so I was looking
for my career got a job as a software
store and I was you know I was didn't
have a tech background so I was teaching
myself all this because the way I look
at Tech is somebody invents it and
everybody else is tied for second place
and the ability to learn it and if if I
work harder and faster to really dive in
if it means reading the manual you know
just diving in then I can get a head
start
24. and so sleeping on the floor working
in a software company you know learning
learning learning learning learning
getting better at what I was doing and
then one day because I was dying to get
out of that rat hole that I lived in
um I had a chance to go out and close
the sale for that would have got me a
1500 commission and so I went to my boss
his name is Michael humeki and I said
boss what are my responsibilities was to
sweep the floor wipe down the windows
and open the door to open the store I
got the sale you got to let me close the
sale he goes no you got to be in there
to open the store and I'm like Michael
you I mean no so I made the executive
decision to go out pick up the check
thinking if I hand this guy a fifteen
thousand dollar check of course he's
going to change his mind
fired me on the spot and so here I was
living in the show excuse my French you
know just this ratty place with a Motel
6 towel sorry Motel six
um and and really didn't know how I was
going to get out but I went to I decided
okay I'm a lousy employee I went to
um one of the companies that I've been
talking to architectural lighting and I
said look
um I need 500 to be able to buy the
software you want and I promise you that
even if it doesn't work I will wash your
car you know I will walk your dog I
don't care what it is I will do whatever
it takes to make it up to you and they
gave me the 500 and that allowed me to
create micro Solutions and you know six
months later I was out of the Rat Hole
and my company turned into a real
company and that's the one I sold for
six million dollars when I was 29 30
years old you talked about
companies having a unique Advantage can
you speak more on that for me please
sure I mean what is it that that a
customer can get from you that they
can't get from anybody else and you have
to be very careful with that too when I
just talked about lying to yourself as
an entrepreneur
because often we'll say well it's just
like uber but it has pink cars Uber
doesn't have pink cars
that that's a difference without a
distinction right lots of times people
get confused between what's a product
and what's a feature pink Uber cars
that's a feature that's not a unique
product
excuse me so you have to know what it is
that you do that is so unique people the
people your potential customers say whoa
I did not know that as opposed to well
let me go tell Uber that they should
probably add pink cars
because whenever you're competing with
you know all of you are going to compete
with Amazon at some point
if you're not already
just the reality and so you've got to
understand when Amazon starts looking at
my customer base what is it that I can
convey to them that makes me unique and
that's that's what I meant by unique
difference you've got to go to afworks
to see our afwork team you just got to
meet some more spark tank finalists what
what advice would you give them on
Innovation and how to take it Forward I
mean learn from what you saw up here I
mean the Brilliance of each and every
one of those ideas is that someone saw a
problem and let me add all of us have
had ideas that we thought were going to
be the next great thing right we get
that feeling in our stomach oh this is
going to be amazing and then you talk
about it with your friends or who you
work with and they say what a great idea
and then most of us stop what you saw up
here and what made it so compelling is
that they didn't stop
it there weren't complicated Solutions
right I mean some of them were Advanced
technologically or they were super smart
but they were simple in that they they
just took basic problems and they tried
to solve them
there's nothing that's that's something
each and every one of us can do and so
the best advice that I can give you is
do it
you know when you have that idea when
you have that opportunity
do it because that's what separates the
people that
just separates the entrepreneurs or the
entrepreneurs
from everybody else they just took that
first step
Don't Be Afraid take that first step
what's the worst thing that can happen
one of the attitude I got for my dad was
you know when you're older and you look
back at your life what would what would
be the things that you remember and
think about that when you say yes or no
to doing something that's really bizarre
or really interesting and so I've tried
to take that attitude whether it was you
know buying the Mavs or doing Dancing
with the Stars or if you really want to
see me embarrass myself and look I have
no problem embarrassing myself is that
all my friends will tell you but if it's
something different and just something
bizarre and interesting I'll do it so if
you turn to TNT tonight there's a show
called drop the mic and you'll see me
rap and I am the world's worst rapper
but it was so much fun and so you know
when I'm 90 years old and I look back
and say should I have done dropped the
mic and wrapped and look like an idiot
hell yes
hell yes right because I got this unique
experience where this professional
rapper taught me how to rap and they
gave me all this stuff and I got to you
know battle with Rusev this guy who
wrestles for WWE who's like five foot
eight and four hundred pounds of muscle
and you know who threatened to kick my
ass in our little battle so it was fun
I'd describe myself as a grinder
um you know I just like we talked about
learning that's a grind but I love it
you know and I just
I think
I've just learned what I'm good at and
learned to focus on those things and and
try to
you know utilize those those skills to
now you know not just be an entrepreneur
but probably more often now invest in
and help other entrepreneurs I grew up
um my dad did upholstery on cars my mom
did odd jobs my mom when I was in high
school was worried about whether or not
I could have a career and you know make
sure she hooked me up with a family
friend to learn how to lay carpet
because she wanted me to know a trade
just in case things didn't pan out
um even when I went to college so yeah
there was it wasn't like oh yeah this is
Destiny and you know my parents are
going to hook me up or you know I knew
this was going to happen it was you know
who the hell knows what's going to
happen but I wasn't I was all in for
wherever Direction it went Michael
Jordan had the body he had the
temperament of a champion so he goes
into sports do you think they call that
bounded rationality instead of saying I
could be every possible thing in the
world you kind of limit it and say all
right I'm more of a math guy oh I'm more
of a people person and then and you try
to find your destiny within that well I
think they go hand in hand right because
the type of person you are that you know
kind of points to the things you're good
at are you 12 you're not going to know
are you 16 you're not going to know if
you're 18 maybe if you have a special
talent yeah right you know you can throw
a baseball 100 miles an hour you can
sing and your voice is incredible you
know you're you know a concert pianist
you're a chess Grand Master if you have
a specific skill set or talent that just
immediately propels you to the top yeah
you want to follow that but I remember
having a list I still have it
um when I graduated from college I was
getting ready to graduate and all the
different industries that I thought I
might want to partake in when you find
something you're good at yeah go for it
yeah and I also also always say it's not
about passion everybody's got passion
for something yeah right don't follow
your passions follow your efforts
because people say you know I was
passionate to play baseball I was
passionate to play basketball it doesn't
mean all of a sudden I was going to be
good enough yeah but I found myself
spending being really curious about
business being really curious about
technology and that curiosity is really
what drove me and I think particularly
if you're young today curiosity is great
always learning and trying to find new
things and being curious about new
things because that's what leads you to
that path trying to figure out in
advance yeah that's hard because you
don't know what you don't know my best
mistake and that's a great question um
probably buying the Mavs everybody told
me I was an idiot and yeah
um just because we were the worst team
in all professional sports and that's
what everybody said and I had paid the
highest price for a sports team up until
that point and everybody said I was a
the the second thing the other
time was after when we sold to Yahoo it
was for 28 million shares of stock and I
immediately colored my stock to protect
it on the downside now this was not when
the Internet stock market was cratering
it was still going up right and so I
colored my stock meaning I didn't really
share and much of the gains going up and
there was a limit to the gains I shared
and Yahoo stock immediately went up 30
percent and um I remember going on CNBC
and they said don't you feel bad about
losing you know it's gone up another 80
points and you'd be worth another 700
million dollars and I was like
it's tough to feel bad when you're
sitting on your G5 watching cnnc
but yeah so coloring my stock everybody
thought was a big mistake because they
thought the market was going to keep on
going up and that's not how it turned
out I started my first business when I
was 12. I was buying and selling um
baseball cards buying and selling stamps
anything I could do to make money I was
hustling and trying to do so I was into
business but I not so much where it was
all my friends were into it with me so
they wouldn't know
baseball cards yeah baseball cards you
name it I mean I grew up in Pittsburgh
and so I would probably even less than
12 years old I would
excuse me go out buy a bunch of baseball
cards that I collected and I would
package I would say okay you're
guaranteed to have a Pittsburgh Pirate
in this package and I would charge three
times as much and I'd set up on this
park bench down in the park down in
Scott Township where I grew up and um
I'd have these little sails and it was
great I made money and I mean it was you
know and I learned as much about
business when I was 9 10 and 12 as I
learned any other time my dad busted his
ass I mean he worked six six days a week
um lit left at seven to seven seven
thirty in the morning got back at six or
seven o'clock lost his eye in an
accident doing upholstery he had a
staple break when he was putting
um
um some
covering on a car seat
um you know it was it was a middle class
upbringing my mom did odd jobs
you know they they just wanted something
better I mean my grandparents came over
from Russia and you know my dad was the
first generation my uncles were the
first generation Americans like my mom
too and you know like every child of
immigrants they wanted better for their
kids you know it's funny I mean a lot of
people grew up that way right but not
many people end up like you so what do
you think that's the result of I think
you know
everybody's got something that they're
good at and the hard part is just
finding it and I found out early that I
was a good salesperson that I really
liked business you know like I like
sports I mean I read everything I
possibly could played Sports as much as
I could just wasn't as good as I wanted
to be and and business was the same way
I mean as long as I could remember I was
buying and selling baseball cards
garbage bags whatever I could find
stamps to collectors but I was also
reading everything I possibly could
about business and you know I was that
unusual kid that I'd rather read about
Ted Turner than go to the movies and and
so I think that created a foundation of
my parents you know my dad used to
always say I don't understand what
you're doing
but I'm glad you're doing it and and so
I had my ups and downs along the way of
course but I just think that
that I just I just put in the time and
was fortunate enough to really get
excited about business and that paid off
benefits over the long
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 50
more amazing roles from Ray dalio check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there you know there's one
sentence that I try to describe
Bridgewater meaningful work and
meaningful relationships through radical
truth and radical transparency so
meaningful work means we're in a mission
together